[Music]
do you condemn riots and burning down
buildings after a police use of force
incident you don't like
no i can i what i'll say is i understand
when a police officer unjustifiably
kills someone why people lash out i
understand that completely i didn't ask
why can't you answer i'm not going to
i'm not going to can you can't answer
nor am i going to condone it
a black lives matter leader making his
message clear after threatening violence
and even bloodshed if new york city's
mayor-elect brings back the city's
anti-crime police unit here with more
from that interview former nypd officer
and unfiltered host dan bongino good
morning dan
hey good to see you good to see you we
watched that interview saturday it's
been all over the internet he stormed
off the set said god bless you but uh
you clearly did not agree and you called
him a coward what's your reaction today
yeah well he is uh you know i really get
tired of all these these fake tough guys
who you know they they want to
implicitly condone violence and the
burning down of other people's property
you know not theirs so he goes out in
front of friendly media hawk he's done
this now a couple times and he does this
like kind of two cute by half wink and
nod like hey you know if violence
happens uh you know might not be a bad
thing i mean bloodshed in the streets
right but i'm not condoning it and then
you know nobody seems to call him out on
it which i find strange so i made the
question very simple i distilled it down
to a very easy answer for him ainsley
that he could have given do you or do
you not
condemn violence in response to a police
use of force incident you don't agree
with the question can't get any simpler
i can tell you my answer no problem i
absolutely condemn violence in response
to police use of forces and incidents i
don't like he couldn't do it it's a
simple question and you know how come
more people in the media the don lemons
and the brian stelters of the world who
by the way have a big problem with kyle
rittenhouse defending his own life when
it's pretty clear his life was in
immediate danger a guy putting a pistol
in his face they can condemn that
immediately and yet they can't condemn a
guy who seems to be winking and nodding
at the burning down and of other
people's property and violence directed
at them even though they had nothing to
do with a police use of force incident i
mean this is just bizarre why does this
guy get a pass the answer is because
he's a protected class he's advocating a
democrat policy and that's a protected
class with today's media they're not you
can't touch them damn i know that you
moved down to florida a lot of others
are doing that too leaving new york high
tax state and more crime up here is that
why we're seeing nypd officers flocking
down to florida now taking jobs there
the governor offering five thousand
dollar bonuses for out-of-state officers
you know i just ran into i'm no joke i
just ran into a guy at a gym this
weekend he was signing up he said hey
you dan from far yeah we got a long
conversation i said what are you doing
down here in florida well my dream job
was the nypd but i'm going to become a
palm beach county sheriff because i had
to get out of new york because you know
you'll find yourself in handcuffs in new
york for arresting people and trying to
get the bad guys off the street and i
thought wow like there's an example
right there in front of you but it just
goes back to that not to go back to the
interview a prior question but another
thing hawk said you know street crime in
new york which were the plane clothes
kind of anti-crime street crime officers
you have no idea if you weren't there
how many guns and bad guys they took off
the street how many black lives were
actually saved by quality plainclothes
policing were there bad incidents
ainsley yes were there abuses of force
of course
but hawks like hey we gotta just we
can't bring that back it just goes to
show you how they don't think deeply
about the issue they think in sound
bites so they can get in the newspaper
and if any people in the media would
call them out we'd have this nonsense
stop tomorrow but they don't they just
give them a pass okay dan thank you so
much i look forward to seeing you
tomorrow dan's going to be at the fox
nation patriot awards we're going to
have a great time it's going to be
streaming on wednesday at 8 p.m eastern
on foxnation.com
see you soon dan
thank you so much for coming on with us
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now